- The one issue, for example,
where I depart pretty strongly
from the traditional
Republican line
is I think a lot of folks
in the Republican Party,
they see what's going on
with Google, Apple, Facebook,
with big tech writ
large and they say,
well, we don't like
what they're doing,
we don't like the fact that
they sensor conservatives,
but they're private companies
and so we can't actually
do anything with them.
And my response to that
is, well, first of all,
they're not actually
private companies,
they benefit from a ton of
special government privileges,
but also they're
just too powerful.
Like however they got there,
they're way too powerful
and they're way too big at this
point, so I'm willing to go
with Ken Buck and with Josh
Hawley and with others and say,
look, we've gotta
actually reign in
the power of these companies
because if they control
what you're allowed
to say in America,
we don't have a First
Amendment anymore.
If we don't have
a First Amendment,
we don't have a real country.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is the author of
"Hillbilly Elegy:
A Memoir of a Family
and Culture in Crisis,"
founder of the venture
capital firm Narya,
and current Senate candidate
from the great state of Ohio.
J.D. Vance, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- Thanks for having me,
Dave, good to see you.
- Good to be with ya.
You know, I've wanted to
chat with you for a while
because I find that on Twitter,
I find some people
who make some sense,
who actually are saying some
things that actually seem
like a sensible way
forward for this country,
for this earth, the whole thing,
you're on that short list.
For people that don't
know who you are,
can you give a little
bit of the backstory,
that's sort of what the book
is about and then the movie,
but can you just give
me a little brief bio
just to kick us off?
- Yeah, sure.
So I was raised by my
working-class grandparents
in Middletown, Ohio, which
is in southwestern Ohio,
it's a steel town,
and the basic story
is because of a host
of complicated reasons,
but one of which is
that my mother struggled
with opioid addiction,
you know, my grandparents
had to take care of me
and we grew up in a pretty
rough and tumble environment,
didn't have a lot of money,
didn't have a lot of support,
but things sort of
worked out for me.
As I like to say,
America worked for me,
and I think it really did
for a number of reasons,
but two reasons at
the top of the list
are my grandma was always
very loving and supportive.
She was, as you know, Dave,
'cause you read the book,
but she was not a traditional
grandmother in a lot of ways.
She loved to say the F word,
she had 19 handguns
when she died,
but she was also a woman
of incredibly deep faith.
And then I also was well-served
by the U.S. Marine Corps
and I enlisted in April of 2003,
which is right as the
Iraq War was ramping up.
You know, Marine Corps is this
incredible experience for me,
gave me a lot of
important lessons,
a lot of lifelong friendships,
and then from there, went to
college, went to law school,
sort of started working
in Silicon Valley
in the technology industry,
got connected with
Peter Thiel out there,
and then while I was
working with Peter actually,
published this book,
"Hillbilly Elegy,"
which happened to coincide,
how could I possibly known
with this remarkable
political environment
that we lived in in 2016 where
Donald Trump on the right,
was coming out of nowhere
and taking over the
Republican Party,
Bernie Sanders was
coming out of the left
and almost taking over
the Democrat Party,
and so I sort of found
myself all of a sudden
a national commentator,
and I'm glad that
you liked my Twitter.
You know, a lot of
your colleagues in
the media don't, but.
(J.D. and Dave laughing)
- I'm not sure
they're my colleagues,
but they are in the
media, whatever that is.
But you bring up an
interesting point there
because yeah, that sort of put
you on the map around 2016.
The Trump thing's
happening and in many ways,
your story and the book
and then the movie,
sort of is the
story of the people
that kind of supported
Trump, right?
- Yeah, it is.
So you think of the story of
my family, so my grandfather
was like a working-class,
Blue Dog Democrat.
He was a classic,
steel union, Democrat.
Socially moderate, very
patriotic, loved his country,
but sort of always saw Democrats
as the party of the working
man and the working women.
By the time Trump
came around in 2016,
most of those
non-college educated
classic white
working-class white voters,
that was sort of the
buzz word in 2016,
they had shifted
so hard to Trump.
And so I think a
lot of the reason
that the book did very well,
is people were picking it up,
trying to understand like
who are all of these voters
who even, you know, a lot of
white working-class voters
actually supported a Barack
Obama in 2008 or 2012,
but had this really
hard shift right
in support of Donald Trump,
and so I think a lot of folk
were trying to understand
what was going on,
and the book obviously
benefited from that.
- Were you surprised
that there was a jump
from those values being in
the middle of the country,
steelworkers, industry's
changing, all that,
and then to an actual
political movement
from a guy who was a real
estate developer in New York?
- You know, it's interesting.
I definitely found the
reaction to the book
as sort of this political
insight into a lot of voters,
a little bit weird 'cause the
book doesn't mention Clinton,
it doesn't mention Trump, it's
not really a political book
in the classic sense,
but I understand
why people were
trying to understand,
like why did these folks in
the middle of the country
feel left behind, so
condescended to, and of course,
they feel left behind,
they feel condescended to
because in many cases,
they actually are.
They have been left behind,
they have been looked down upon
by a lot of folks in power,
so I appreciate that people
were at least for a brief period
trying to understand that
demographic of the country.
So, obviously the book
benefited from that
and I think hopefully it
did provide some insights
from that group of people
or to that group of people.
- Yeah, you mentioned
the Blue Dog Democrat.
I'm not sure how much
you know about my story,
but I was a lefty, I was a
progressive, the whole thing,
but I would say if the Blue
Dog Democrats still existed,
but they're basically like
the unicorn at this point,
there would be maybe
some room for me to say
I could kinda be on that side,
probably not at this point,
but do you think that
person exists anymore
and if they do exist,
are they basically just
a modern conservative?
I mean, is that sort of
what you are at this point?
- Yeah, I think that the people
like that certainly exist,
I think Donald Trump fits into
that, where to your point,
even though he was a
real estate developer,
I think he's at his cart,
he's a guy from Queens
who works with a lot of
working-class people,
construction workers,
salespeople, and so forth,
and so he's always
identified with those folks
at a deep emotional level and
they've identified with him.
You know, Donald
Trump is up there,
I certainly think my
attitude towards politics
is like a working class or
a blue collar conservatism.
There were other people out
there, I think Jim Banks
is a really interesting guy,
a representative from Indiana,
I think Tucker Carlson,
talk about another guy
who's sort of an East Coast,
WASP in the classic sense,
but I think identifies
with blue collar folks
in a very deep way
and obviously focuses a
lot on them in his show,
so I think there are actually
a lot of us out there
who think the purpose
of the Republican Party
should be to better
serve its voters,
but I think they're all on
the right at this point.
I mean, there were maybe a
couple of Blue Dog Democrats,
even five, 10 years ago,
they all got primary,
they all got effectively
kicked out of the party,
and they're just clearly
not welcome there anymore,
so if they exist at all,
they're sort of our
side of the aisle.
- Yeah, I mean, that's
what I've been saying.
I know a few of these people
and I think it's kind
of a worthy fight
if you wanna still
say you're a Democrat
and try to do something as
the house is burning down,
but it just doesn't seem
like it could work to me.
Are you surprised how
radical the left has gone,
that there is no room
for these people?
I mean, I guess as someone
running for Senate now,
you're kind of excited.
It's like, yeah, come over
here, we're all right.
(J.D. chuckles)
- I'm definitely surprised
and a little startled
by how crazy the left has
gone over the last 10 years.
I mean, in part,
this is a consequence
of demographics, right?
The left is basically the party
of upper middle-class
and upper-class elites,
and then some
working-class minorities
who are sort of still
along for the ride
on the Democratic Party,
but really those folks
don't have a ton of influence
in the party, right?
So it's partially just sort
of who is leading the left.
I think it's like, you know,
professionally educated people
who went to Ivy league schools
who tend to have pretty
radical views about politics
because of it.
I think a little of it
is definitely economic,
I think that the left is not
comfortable with the fact
that a lot of people
are dissatisfied
with the way the
economy has worked,
the way the manufacturing
and instead of saying,
you know, maybe this
is a serious problem
that we've like lost
our entire manufacturing
and industrial base to China,
I think their response is
to complain that the people
who care about our industrial
base in the first place,
they're obviously racist
or xenophobic radiates.
So I think part
of what's going on
is it's just like the
composition of the left
has really radically changed,
but then part of what's going on
is the left, completely
unable to solve
America's real problems
and sort of resorted
to criticizing most
Americans as backwards
or racist in some way, and so,
yeah, it's really startling,
it's really depressing, but
you know, it is where we is,
and you know, it is what it
is, and I think, unfortunately,
we just have to
fight these people.
- Where do you think Trump
now fits into this thing?
Because you were not onboard
the Trump train in 2016, right?
You did vote for him in 2020.
Where do you think
he sort of is now,
like the worth of
Trump at this point?
- Oh yeah, you're right, I
was a late adopter to Trump
and I remember Peter Thiel
giving me crap for it
back in 2016, and of
course, eventually I said,
you know, you're
right, you we're right.
The guy was saying a
lot of smart things,
did support him in 2020.
I mean, I think at
a fundamental level,
Trump is still the leader of
the Republican Party, right?
So to the extent that you have
this blue collar patriotic
movement within the country,
it's on the right,
most of those voters are still
very loyal to Donald Trump,
and so I think he continues
to have a very important voice
either as a king
maker in the party,
certainly I think
if he ran in 2024
there's a very good chance he'd
get elected president again,
so I tend to think that
Trump is not gonna disappear
as a force from
American public life.
And I think, you
know, unfortunately,
most Republicans or at least
most Republican leaders,
I think most Republican voters
are very good about this,
most Republican leaders
I think don't fully appreciate
what Trump represented,
and so there isn't an
obvious like answer to Trump
if he just disappeared tomorrow.
I do fear a little bit
that if Trump just went
the way of the Dodo,
you know, decided, well, I'm
gonna focus on making money
or I'm gonna go
play golf all day
and not really worry
about politics anymore,
like, I don't know that
there's an obvious person
to replace him, right?
There's some really good
people like DeSantis,
like Josh Hawley,
but outside of a few
really bright politicians,
I think most people
don't wanna fully embrace
what Trump represented
for the Republican Party,
which is a tragedy, 'cause
I think it's ultimately,
you know, equivocal with
some things on the margins,
but I think it's the right
direction for the party to go.
- Right, so you're saying guys
like the DeSantis and Hawley
are better than
Romney and Liz Cheney,
is that the controversial
statement you're making?
- Yeah, the radical
claim that I would make
is the Josh Hawley is much
better than Liz Cheney
and Ron DeSantis is
better than Mitt Romney.
But again, unfortunately
I actually think
the most elected Republicans
are not as far out there
as Liz Cheney.
They really don't like
what Trump represents.
They sort of want the
party to be what it was
during the Bush era, 2000, 2004,
and because of that, there's
still a lot of resistance.
I mean, even one of
the big takeaways
from the Trump administration
is that when the entire party
is institutionally set against
the will of the
president himself,
there can be a lot of
real bureaucratic fights,
and I think so much
of what happened
during the Trump administration
is the Trump folks wanted
to do something on trade,
they were somewhat successful,
they were also fought by
members of their own party,
and so you don't just
need one politician,
you sort of need the entire
institution to reform itself.
- Right, so where do
you fit into that,
like in terms of your
beliefs at this point?
Are they all traditionally
conservative?
I mean, I get what
you're saying,
you could maybe be thought
of as one of those,
you know, 15-year-ago
Blue Dog Democrat types,
but like what would say
your broad sort of
idea set look like?
- Yeah, I mean,
there are some traditionally
conservative ideas
that I'm very comfortable with.
So I'm very pro-life,
I've always been pro-life,
I've always cared a
lot about that issue
because I think when abortion
becomes widespread in society,
what it effectively does is
send a message to families
that their babies
are inconveniences
instead of real like
blessings for us to support.
So on some issues I'm very
traditionally conservative,
you know, but like one
issue, for example,
where I depart pretty strongly
from the traditional
Republican line
is I think a lot of folks
in the Republican Party,
they see what's going on
with Google, Apple, Facebook,
with big tech writ
large, and they say,
well, we don't like
what they're doing,
we don't like the fact that
they sensor conservatives,
but they're private companies
and so we can't actually
do anything with them,
and my response to that is,
well, first of all, they're
not actually private companies,
they benefit from a ton of
special government privileges,
but also they're
just too powerful.
Like however they got there,
they're way too powerful
and they're way too
big at this point,
so I'm willing to
go with Ken Buck
and with Josh Hawley and
with others and say, look,
we've gotta actually reign in
the power of these companies
because if they control
what you're allowed
to say in America,
we don't have a First
Amendment anymore.
If we don't have
the First Amendment,
we don't have a real country.
- Yeah, it's interesting
because I've discussed this
with Tucker on his
show many times,
and years, like two
or three years ago,
I was still like no regulation,
don't touch anything,
the libertarian side of me,
and I actually have
come more towards
what you just laid out there,
which is what Josh
Hawley's been laying out.
But what do you think
that actually looks like?
Because if the founders
could have never imagined
something more powerful
than the government,
which is what we've got,
I mean, do you wanna send
government bureaucrats
to look at the Google algorithm
as if they could do it
or is it breaking
these companies up?
I mean, I know you like
the competition side
and we'll talk about Rumble
in just a little bit,
but like what does
it actually look like
that you would want
done to big tech?
- Yeah, yeah, so yeah,
bracketing the things
you can still do in
the private sector,
which I think is important,
I think that there
are ranges of options
from less radical to
more radical, right?
So I think the slightly
less radical option
is you just make in the same way
that like you can't censor
somebody because they're black
or because they're white.
Well, you know, you used
to not be able to do that,
of course, the last
couple of years.
(J.D. laughs)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
give it a couple more months.
- You know, you can't
for example, turn off,
an electric utility can't
turn off somebody's power
because they don't like the
sex or the gender or the race
of the people who
need the power.
I think one thing you
could do is just add
political viewpoint to
that protected class.
Say if you're a conservative
and you're censored on Facebook,
you basically have a
right to file a lawsuit
in the same way that
if you're censored
because you're black, you have
a right to file a lawsuit.
That's sort of option one.
I think a little bit more
radical is the antitrust option,
effectively breaking
up these companies,
making it impossible for
them to sort of control
the discourse because
you have more competition
among the platforms
that are out there.
You know, I'm basically
supportive of that,
though I think you have
to do it the right way
or effectively these sort
of companies just reform
as natural monopolies.
The thing that I'm
really intrigued by
is like, does the business
model of Silicon Valley
actually makes sense, right?
So, you know, I have
my iPhone right here,
if you think about
like what an iPhone is,
it really is a thing that
gets you to stare at it
as much as possible so
that it can take your data
and then sell it back to you
in the form of
targeted advertising.
There's a pretty good argument
that the Silicon
Valley business model,
which distracts a
lot of attention
and effectively is built
upon the theft of data
should be completely
outlawed, right?
Make it illegal to sort
of collect people's data
without a whole host of
additional protections.
I think that would blow up
the model of Silicon Valley,
I think maybe
that's too radical,
but if I'm actually
laying my cards out.
- Hey, as a guy that just
started a tech company
that's doing subscription
and doesn't sell data,
keep it going, keep it going.
- Yeah, but I had to
say that honestly,
I would be supportive of that.
If you basically said
you can no longer effectively
steal people's data,
I think that would be
really good for our country
and I actually think it would
be good for the tech sector
because like the tech sector,
whether it's in digital
technology or pharmaceuticals
or energy and transportation,
like it's become a little
bit, like these devices,
I think have become a
little parasitic on capital,
on high quality talent,
and there's this weird way
where our entire economy,
like Silicon Valley
has worked pretty well,
if you look at the S&P 500,
Silicon Valley has great
returns in their companies,
but like the entire
rest of the country
and the entire
rest of the economy
has been relatively stagnant.
That's a big problem.
That's not just a
censorship problem,
that's a broader
economic problem,
but I think we have to be
worried about that problem too,
so I'm pretty radical on this.
In other words,
go after their special
privileges, break them up,
maybe even illegalize the
entire business model,
because I care about
having a real economy
in a real country again.
- At some level though,
do you think it's
just kinda too late?
Like we had Trump for four
years, we had all the hearings,
we all saw Zuckerberg
and Jack from Twitter
and the rest of them trot out
there and basically make up
a lot of nonsense half
the time under oath,
and we didn't do anything then,
so why would the Biden
administration that obviously
is no fan of some of the ideas
you're putting out there,
why would they be
the ones to do this?
- Well, I don't think they're
gonna be the ones to do this.
I mean, I definitely think
it's gonna be a combination
of leverage from
Republican senators,
and hopefully I'm one in
the not too distant future,
it's also gonna require a new
Republican administration.
I think, again,
all of this stuff
is gonna happen on the
right because the left
is way too in the pocket
of the big tech industry.
All that said, you know,
I try to take a very
long view in this.
You may know this
guy, Nigel Farrage,
he's sort of the
leader of the UPA.
- I've gotten drunk with him.
- Okay, well, yeah, he's a
good guy to have a beer with.
You know, one of the
things that I've taken
just from getting to
know Nigel a little bit,
is like the Brexit
thing took 25 years
of institution building,
of convincing voters,
of convincing media, a ton
of institutional biases
against the Brexit movement,
electorally there were
some weird issues,
of course, the media
hated Nigel Farrage
and thought he was
a terrible person,
so I tend to think about
this in a longer-term way,
that like the goal here
isn't to fix this tomorrow.
Yes, you know, I wish that
more could have happened
over the last four years
in actually addressing
the tech problem,
but I think if we
take that attitude
it can become self-defeating
and what we have to
do in this moment
is actually gear
ourselves up for a fight,
in a long-term fight,
and if we do that,
I actually think the
people are with us,
I think that we're on the
right side of this issue
and we'll eventually win,
it just may take some
work and a lot of time.
- Yeah, do you think we just
need a sort of separation
from all of the institutions
that the left has built
that we're now watching crumble?
I mean, do we need to just
build new institutions,
new technological
answers and solutions,
just really like a
complete parallel economy?
- Yeah, I mean, I
think we probably do.
We need to build parallel
businesses of course,
because the businesses
have gone fully in
the tank for the left,
like the biggest
multinational corporations
are now effectively
enterprises of the left.
I also think we have to build
alternative educational
institutions.
You know, one of the things
the left has been
incredibly effective at
is monopolizing education
in this country, right?
They basically created a system
whereby if you don't get a
four year college degree,
it's very hard to even apply
for most middle-class
jobs, right?
Even if they don't really
require a college degree,
they'll put it right
on the application,
like, you know, four
year degree required.
And so what this has done
is forced a lot of people
who just wanna have
a middle-class life
into the university system,
they've acquired a lot of debt,
they've of course acquired
a lot of indoctrination
along the way,
like the left is in some ways
like in this evil Machiavellian
sense, sort of genius
because they've made the most
left-leaning institutions
the gatekeeper of a good
life in this society.
Conservatives have got to
find an alternative to this
because if we keep on
forcing all of our kids
to go to four year colleges,
we shouldn't be surprised
that we keep on losing
the culture war.
- Yeah, I always describe it
as the doctor in the
original "Alien" movie.
You know, he kind of
admires the pure evil,
the complete, remorseless
evil of the alien.
He knows it's evil,
but he's kinda like,
hey, you gotta give
the devil his due.
But so all that being said,
you also have a VC firm,
and you're actually getting
in the fight right now
by getting involved with Rumble.
Can you talk about
that a little bit?
- Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, so we launched our
VC firm in Cincinnati.
You know, I'd been in VC,
the industry for a few years,
I always wanted to do
something in my hometown,
so we launched it as a
Cincinnati-based firm in 2019,
you know, myself, a partner,
and a couple of our
employees who are great,
and we like on the one hand,
we're just a classic
VC firm, right?
We try to invest in
really good companies
and help them grow.
You know, one of the companies
that I'm most proud
of that we invested in
is a company called App Harvest,
which is an agricultural
technology company
in Eastern Kentucky,
now has a close to $2
billion market cap,
when we invested it was really
just in its formative stages,
so a lot of good
stuff happening,
but yeah, one of the
companies I'm most proud
that we got involved
with was Rumble.
And, I know you know
a lot about Rumble,
but the thinking
there was actually
we were sort of looking at
a lot of the alternative
tech platforms
in the wake of January
the sixth, right?
It's like, okay,
this is pretty scary,
the president of
the United States
just got booted off
of social media,
maybe these companies
are too powerful.
You know, let's look at
Gab, let's look at Parlor,
let's look at a lot of the
companies that are out there
that are actually providing
something like free speech
to people who wanna live
in the digital world,
and, you know, liked
a lot of the companies
that we looked at, couldn't
quite get comfortable
that they were actually
robust enough technology
to withstand what eventually,
you know, the
de-platforming incident
that came against Parlor that
effectively shut the site down
for a couple of months, and
so, but just kept on looking
and we finally met Chris,
who's the CEO and the founder
of Rumble who I
know you know well,
and started like talking
to Chris and thinking,
okay, so, you
know, first of all,
their user metric
numbers are incredible,
they're growing at a
really remarkable clip,
they've never had an
infusion of capital
so they've sort of done all
of this growth organically,
but also Chris had
built the platform
not to be like a conservative
website or a liberal website,
but just to be a true
alternative website.
Like the technology was
robust, we felt like, well,
if AWS tries to
de-platform this company,
they're not gonna be
able to be successful
because of the way that Chris
had built the
underlying technology,
and so just eventually
got really excited
about what they were doing,
made a big investment there,
brought Peter Thiel
along into the deal,
he also made a big
investment into the company,
and now it's growing at
a really amazing clip
and we think that this could be
a true independent, apolitical
alternative to big tech.
- Right, so I don't wanna
say too much at the moment,
but I am having dinner in
Miami with Chris on Friday,
so I'll leave that part there.
But in essence,
is the goal that you guys
sort of wanna replace AWS,
that you guys would
basically say,
hey, we've got all of
the infrastructure.
Chris is an engineer,
he's been building this
thing for 10 years,
like we've got
the infrastructure
so that you won't just
be blown up like Parlor.
Because you're right,
that was the moment
where it was like everyone
realized this thing,
just the severity
of the situation
just went through the roof.
- That's right, yeah.
More even than Trump
being de-platformed,
Parlor being effectively
kicked off the internet
was really radicalizing to me
and to a lot of
other people as well.
You know, certainly
one of the options,
I'll put it this way.
One of the options I think
for Rumble is to become
a long-term, apolitical,
true free speech, AWS, right?
The sort of online web platform
that's not gonna de-platform you
because you say things
that the mob doesn't like.
But one of the
things I've learned
working in the technology sector
is you always try
to have a good plan
and you execute against it,
but there are a lot
of forks in the road,
and I think Rumble has 10
different pathways to the moon.
Like this is not a company
that just has one real
option to go after,
and what I think actually,
you know, there's always
challenges with companies
and one of the challenges
with Rumble that I think about
is they have such a
big market opportunity,
they have so much they could
do, that I think focusing
and picking the right
strategic pathway
is almost gonna be
the biggest challenge
because the company, again,
they're just doing really well
and they've got a
lot of real upside.
- Right, and not to do too
much of a commercial here,
but you guys had the Trump
rally a couple of days ago
livestreamed on Rumble,
over 500,000 people.
I think Biden's speech
yesterday or the day before,
18,000 people on YouTube.
So, something good's
going on over there.
- Yeah, that's exactly
right, 500,000 people.
And being able to handle
that amount of traffic
as a new company is not easy
so we were really
pleased with it.
- Yeah, so as this ecosystem
kinda comes together,
are there other pieces
that you think we need
to be thinking about
that maybe we're
not thinking about?
- Well, the thing that
we're not thinking about,
I think is just how--
- You know, payment
processors, et cetera.
- You know, exactly,
is how truly unstable
the entire online
ecosystem is, right?
You mentioned
payment processors.
There's sort of the Domain
Registration Services,
that's a big question.
There are sort of, you
know, CDN services.
That's a big question
mark that I have.
You know, if you get
really far down the line
and the tech companies feel
extraordinarily powerful,
do you get to a point where
if you type in a website
on a mobile browser, the
browser won't actually resolve?
Like that's sort of the hallmark
of a free and open internet
is that if you type in a
website, you go to that website,
do the browsers themselves
start becoming
agents of censorship?
So what's crazy about
the internet I mean,
is that there are probably 40
or 50 really critical layers
that make it work from sort
of payments processing,
front end services, all the
way down to the backend stuff
that 99% of people
don't see or care about,
but at each level there
are only a few companies
that actually control
things, right?
And so it's not inconceivable
that you have an internet
where people can't
have access to it
if they're not
sufficiently left wing.
That's sort of a big
concern that I have
and I think that there
are a lot of good folks,
you know, a lot of good firms
that are working on ensuring
there are alternatives
that are truly committed
to free speech, so I'm
somewhat optimistic
that some of these
alternatives are coming online,
but I do in some way
see this as like a race
against the future,
because the left is,
as you know, is not
becoming less crazy,
it's actually
becoming more crazy.
And, you know, once they
control the information,
they really control
the way all of us think
and that's pretty much it.
- Yeah, is that part of
the problem right there,
that there's just
sort of an asymmetry
of who likes to use power?
I've been talking about
that a lot on the show,
just that we don't
really wanna use power,
even in this conversation.
It's like, ah, you know,
competition, government,
it's like we're sort of okay
with competing ideas
being out there,
where when they have the
power, we know what they do.
- Yeah, that's exactly right.
You know, people always
ask me the difference
between left and right.
Is it small government,
big government,
social conservative,
progressive, what have you,
and I always say, look,
the big difference
between the left and right is
the left loves to use power
and the right is
terrified of using power.
And you know, my friend
Richard Hananiah,
who's a really interesting
thinker on this,
he says the left
loves to use power
because they actually
care about politics more.
Like, you know,
you look at polling
and the right just doesn't
care as much about politics
as the left does.
I think, unfortunately
we're in an environment
where we have to get over it
because if we're not
willing to use power
to push back against the left,
I think that power
is gonna come for us,
it's gonna come for
our livelihoods,
it's gonna come
for our families,
it's gonna come eventually,
it already started,
coming for our
variability to speak
and to think for ourselves.
And so I agree, the left has
a basic instinctive advantage
because they love to use power,
but we're just gonna
have to get over it
or we're gonna find ourselves
without really a real
Republic anymore.
- Yeah, do you see
any sort of version
of any of this ecosystem,
where there has to be some
regulations around speech?
This is where the gatekeeping
conversation always comes in.
You know, are you gonna let
Antifa coordinate on there
on one side versus
neo-Nazis on another side
or something like that?
- You know, obviously
there's some regulation
in every sphere, and I tend
to think that, you know, look,
we've had a First Amendment
in our country for 245 years
and it's worked pretty well,
and the basic outline
of the First Amendment
is that you're allowed
to speak your mind,
you're allowed to say the
things that you wanna say,
so long as you effectively
don't incite violence
against other people, right?
There are very narrow limits
on what you're allowed to say,
but there are some limits
and I think that's fine.
And I think that
should be the hallmark
to how we think about
the regulation of speech
is we should be open
to hearing a debate
so long as it doesn't run a foul
of the basic principles
of the First Amendment.
Now importantly,
like this doesn't,
you know, I think a lot
of folks on the left
like to retreat and
say, well, you know,
are you not allowed to sort of
regulate a school curriculum?
For example, if you don't
want to teach four-year-olds
or eight-year-olds that
they should hate America
and that America
is a fundamentally
white supremacist country,
is that like a violation
of the First Amendment?
And I think, no, of
course, it isn't, right?
We've long understood
that the way we treat kids
is different from the
way we treat adults
and the purpose of our schools
is to form people,
form young minds
for future leadership
and future citizenship,
so I think the First Amendment
doesn't apply everywhere, right?
It applies to a 19-year-old
much differently
than it applies to
a three-year-old,
but I think that should
be our guiding principle.
- Yeah, that's actually exactly
where I want it to go next.
All this critical
race theory stuff,
and that it's being pushed
back against in certain states,
what's going on
in Ohio with this?
Is that one of the states that
they're making any headway
with getting some of this
stuff out of the schools?
- Yeah, it really does
feel like we're making
a lot of headway in Ohio
as a matter of fact.
I mean, we're starting to see
even, you know, I live
in southwestern Ohio,
biggest city here is Cincinnati,
and I'm starting to see
stuff in some of the suburban
Cincinnati school districts
where parents are starting to
push back against this stuff.
You know, you see them
starting to mobilize
to take over some
local school boards,
you have stay-at-home moms
who never really
cared about politics,
who are thinking about running
for a local school board,
and you also have some
curriculum stuff happening,
some of the state organizations
are really pushing back
against some of the
curriculum that's coming
unfortunately, from
our universities
and some of our state
leaders saying, look,
you shouldn't be teaching
kids to hate themselves
or hate their own country.
You know, one of the most
heartbreaking stories I've heard
in the last few
weeks was from a dad
who pulled his fifth
grader out of school
in a suburban Cincinnati
school district,
and, you know, we often
talk about this stuff
in two abstract terms, right?
Like critical race theory
is itself an abstract term,
but this guy pulled his
daughter out of school
because she was coming
home really sad every day,
being taught that she was
effectively a bad person
for having white skin,
and you think about
the struggles we've
had in this country
and what we've been fighting for
and I think progressing towards,
it's like aren't we supposed
to think about people
based not on their skin color?
Aren't we supposed to be
teaching our kids to look deeper
than skin color in how they
judge and evaluate people?
And this just feels like a
really radical step backwards
in the wrong direction
and it's actually
making our kids unhappy.
That's what really
bothers me about this.
- Yeah, so you're old school,
you think that that MLK
guy was pretty decent, huh?
(J.D. laughs)
- You know, I think the
idea that we judge people
by the content of
their character
is a pretty good principle to
live by and it's unfortunate
that the left seems unwilling
to even follow it these days.
- Yeah, so what other
policies or platforms
that you're running on that
are unique to Ohio right now?
- You know, the big
thing we're focused on
is the tech issue,
the immigration issue.
You know, people think,
I think people understand
the immigration question
as fundamentally about law and
order, and it is that, right?
You don't have a real country
unless you have a southern
border with enforced limits,
but in Ohio, one of the things
the southern border means to
us is the addiction epidemic
gets much, much worse
when you don't control
what's going on at
the southern border.
So for example, a few weeks ago,
Biden administration reported
that you've seen fentanyl
seizures go up four times
over the same period last year,
when I think Trump,
to his credit,
had a lot of control
over the southern border.
That's what kills people
in our communities, right?
So eventually that fentanyl
is gonna start making it to
southwestern Ohio communities,
it's gonna mean more dead bodies
from the addiction epidemic,
and people just, you
know, I always hate
when the immigration
issue is framed
as about xenophobia or racism.
Like you've got a grandma who's
taking care of a grandbaby
because her own daughter
died of a heroin overdose,
she doesn't care about
the southern border
'cause she doesn't
like brown people,
she cares about
the southern border
because she doesn't
want her grandson
to die of the same poison
that killed her daughter.
Like this is just common sense.
So the border's a
big thing for us,
obviously the big tech
issue is a big thing for us,
and the thing we haven't talked
about is I'm a big believer
that unless you have
an industrial base,
a manufacturing base, you don't
have a real country, right?
If you can't make
pharmaceuticals,
if you can't make surgical
masks for your doctors,
if you can't make like
basic computer hardware
that's necessary to operate
your defense industry,
then you're fundamentally at
the mercy of another country.
Like we're getting to the
point where six years from now,
we could find ourselves
in a situation
where we have the same
missiles as China does,
but China's missiles work
because they have
computer chips in them
and our missiles don't
because the Chinese
control the computer chip
industry in the entire world.
Like this is really crazy
and this is unfortunately
something that leadership
in both parties
has been complicit in,
so we're gonna talk a
lot about manufacturing
and the manufacturing
economy in our campaign too.
- Where do you think that
stuff really comes from?
Like is it just that sort
of because of the success
of America for
200-almost-50 years,
and capitalism and the
extraordinary wealth
and everything else that
we just sorta got sold off
piece by piece and it's like,
it was sort of nobody's fault
and everybody's fault
at the exact same time?
Like there's just sort of
nobody left to fix everything.
- Yeah, I think
that's exactly right.
I think two big
things happen is one,
we felt that we could trade
our manufacturing economy
for a lot of cheap
consumer goods, right?
To put it as dismissively as
possible, we thought, well,
you know, maybe we'll lose
millions of manufacturing jobs,
but we'll gain a lot of cheap
plastic garbage from China.
I think that was a trade
that we should not
have made in hindsight,
but I think to your
point, more importantly,
we forgot I think one of
the core historical lessons
of the American nation state,
which is that it was built
by an American
capitalist system, right?
Our government was not
overbearing, but it made sure
that core American industries
could prosper and flourish
in this country,
and importantly,
the Japanese and the Chinese
learned from the American model
in building their own
industrial economy.
It's really a model that's
worked the world over
and we sort of just
forgot and ignored it.
We sort of decided that we
didn't really need to have
certain industries,
you know, the law of
competitive advantage.
It was fine if Chinese
made this thing
and the Americans
had made this thing
and the Canadians
made that thing,
but it turns out that
like maybe the Canadians
are a little bit more
reliable than the Chinese
for like complex cultural and
national security reasons,
and certainly maybe Minnesota
is much more reliable
than Canada or the Chinese
for some of these core needs,
and so I think we just
stopped seeing the economy
as a thing that was
sensitive to human control,
we thought that it would
just work by itself,
but of course, all
of our regulations,
all of our tax policy, all
of our laws were affecting
that market in ways we
were just kind of ignoring.
- Do you think it's also
that we kinda took our eye
off the ball with four
years of screaming
that Trump was a Russian plant,
while China was actually
doing a lot of the stuff
that was gonna get us here?
- Yeah, that's definitely right.
I mean, we definitely learned
over the last four years
that the media especially
can be easily distracted.
It's like, you know,
look a squirrel, right?
Look, Russia, look,
Vladimir Putin,
and we all have these
really serious problems.
Look, racism, right?
I mean, you couldn't even
talk about the origins
of the Chinese coronavirus
for a long time
until it became
almost idiotic not to,
because that was considered
racist to ask the origin.
So I think, unfortunately,
we have a leadership
class in this country.
You see it in the businesses,
you see it in the media,
you certainly see it
in the government,
that is just
completely unwilling
to talk about real problems
and uses these distractions
so that we basically
don't notice the fact
that they're all failing us.
- So what do we do about
the mainstream media?
Do we just let it, do we
let it die at this point?
Almost every day on the show
I have to do some nonsensical
story about what CNN butchered
or what "Washington
Post" lied about,
and then I always pose the
question to my audience,
I'm like, should I just
start ignoring this stuff
because we know their
numbers are bottoming out
or do we have to keep
calling attention to it
because they still are
brainwashing X amount of people?
- I think it's a
little bit of both.
I think that we have to
try to extract ourselves
from reliance on the mainstream
media as much as possible,
but I also think it is
important to recognize,
like your show probably
has way more viewers
than any CNN show on
any given day, right?
- I've got one guy in this
room with me, that's it.
(J.D. laughs)
That's it and my
dog's under the table.
- That's right.
(J.D. laughs)
So we are actually
benefiting in some ways
from the rise of
alternative media sources.
I mean, I think actually
where I worry about this
as sort of the
fusion of government
and media and big
business, right?
Like the "Washington Post,"
you should understand
is effectively the
mouthpiece of Jeff Bezos.
You know, a lot of our biggest
newspapers and magazines
are effectively
controlled by business,
and in some ways influenced
by governmental interests.
That sort of unholy alliance
is what I really worry about,
is like, okay, so Jeff Bezos
owns the "Washington Post,"
he just effectively
lobbied the U.S. Congress
to cancel a grant given to one
of his business competitors.
This just happened in
the last couple of days
for a space company,
Blue Origin,
where now they've
canceled the contract,
they may re-award
the contract to him,
and you sort of start to wonder,
like isn't this a
really icky system
where you have media
cooperating with government,
cooperating with business to
control the flow of information
and control which
decisions get made?
I actually think you can
probably break the circuit
and in interesting ways,
and we should try to do that
because yes, the
media is weaker,
but it's still
incredibly powerful.
- Yeah, so is that just
through competition then?
I mean, this is the
breaking of the circuit
that we're gonna
build all this stuff
and then people, they'll
have an off ramp?
- You know, I think it's a
little bit through competition.
I mean, I've heard
proposals that suggest
that like part of the reason
the media is a little bit less
crazy in Europe for example,
is that they have more of a
historical First Amendment,
whereas in America
you have this weird,
trumped up First Amendment
where the media can
effectively lie about people
without any real consequences,
and so maybe we need to
sort of go back to an era
where there's a little
bit more consequence
if the media just tells an
outright lie about somebody.
Like, you know, if
I'm a private citizen,
I tell a lie about you
that causes you to
lose your business,
you can sue me for defamation.
It's basically impossible
to sue the media
for defamation these days,
so there maybe are policy
changes to be made there too.
You know, I wouldn't sort
of fully go down that road
just yet because I do
think the alternative media
is actually rising in a way
that gives me some optimism.
- Yeah, you know, to your
point a couple of weeks ago,
someone in the "New
York Times," once again,
basically called me
a white supremacist
and I spoke to a lawyer
just for a second,
and I've been through
this, just like you,
I've been through
this a million times,
and she's a great
First Amendment lawyer,
and she was
basically like, look,
you could dump a ton
of money into this,
but these laws are so tight
that most likely they
have more money than you
and this isn't gonna go anywhere
and it's just gonna
be a headache.
And you know what?
Somehow we just, we all survived
being called white
supremacists somehow.
- Yeah, that's exactly right.
I've had similar conversations.
I've been called a
white supremacist
by the "Washington Post"
and it is really crazy
how it's impossible
for people to face
any consequences for
this stuff, right?
It's kind of this
crazy wild, wild west
where there's just no real law.
I mean, you remember the
Covington Catholic kid
who was effectively slandered
by every mainstream
journalist all over the world?
That kid, fortunately,
as I understand,
has gotten some settlement,
but even that kid,
my understanding
is like it was not totally clear
that this 17-year-old boy
would have any recourse,
even though the entire
mainstream press
came against him.
That's pretty depressing stuff.
- Yeah, not only the
mainstream press,
but half of the
Democrats in Congress
were saying how this is proof
that America is a white
supremacist nation
and it turns out that
it was all nonsense.
- Exactly, including our
now sitting vice-president.
- Yeah.
(Dave chuckles)
Speaking of our
sitting vice-president,
let's talk about the
president for a second.
I've been saying for a while
that the scandal is the
non-scandal around this guy.
Something is not right with him.
It seems very obvious.
Everyone online is
talking about it,
yet no one in corporate
press is talking about it.
Like, I dunno,
what do you think?
(Dave chuckles)
- You know, I don't know.
I mean, if you've ever known
somebody with dementia,
one of the things
you always notice
is that they'll have
this quick moment
where they forget
where they are,
they almost get like a sense
of terror across their face,
and then they recover.
This is sort of
earlier onset dementia,
this is not when people
are really advanced.
And there are some times
like Biden reacts in a way
where I almost think
he has that look,
that sort of look where he
forgot where he was a second,
remembered it very quickly,
but you watch the guy
on the world stage,
you watch him in some
of these meetings
and it's just very clear
that he's lost something,
he's missed a step.
I don't know if that's like,
you know, he's just older
and he's aged less
gracefully than other people,
or if he actually has
a serious problem,
but I find it bizarre that
people never talk about this.
I mean, you probably remember
a couple of years ago,
like it was a serious
mainstream story to ask
whether Donald Trump had
like dementia or Alzheimer's.
Because he like mangled
a sentence in a speech
or something like that,
or he got like, you know, he
said the same thing a few times
in some remarks.
- He drank water
like this, remember?
- He drank water like that.
- Two hands.
- And it's like the
guy has Alzheimer's,
and it's like, you know,
if you've ever met Trump,
like he does not come across
as a guy who doesn't
know where he is.
And Biden is just so
much worse on this,
and yet the press is
totally uninterested in it.
I find it pretty bizarre.
The other side of
this that is weird
is that it makes you wonder,
like who actually
has control, right?
Is it the White
House chief of staff?
Is it the vice president?
Is it some other staffer,
but like who's making
the decisions there?
Like I'd love to actually
see just a good documentary
or piece of reporting
about what's actually,
or who is actually in
control in the White House.
- That's exactly what I asked
Trump about two weeks ago.
Who do you think is in charge?
He actually didn't
have a great answer,
but all the time now we
see Biden get out there,
he fumbles through
something and then he says,
"Oh, I'm gonna get in trouble."
It's like, with who?
- That's right.
(J.D. laughs)
That's right.
- With like, come on, to quote
Joe Biden, "Come on, man."
Like with who are you
gonna get in trouble?
But we just don't know.
So you think Kamala is
taking over at some point?
- You know, I always assumed,
you know, I've become
more conspiracy-minded
just because it
seems like our elites
really are sometimes malicious,
and my assumption is that Kamala
will eventually take over,
maybe it's in 2024
as the candidate,
maybe it's even
earlier than that.
I mean, if Joe Biden resigns
in the next two years,
there is nothing that you will
be able to do to convince me
this was not a
massive conspiracy
to install a very
unpopular person,
but like, you know, I'll save
the speculation until later.
My sense is that like
the corporate wing
of the Democrat Party recognizes
like Kamala's their gal,
but also even the voters
of the Democrat Party
don't like her, and so there's
some sort of weird bargain
going on where she's eventually
gonna assume the mantle
without real democratic
control over the process,
and you know, of course,
the country's gonna be
that worse off for it,
but hopefully, you know,
on our side and we can
stop that from happening.
- Right, so to get us
back where we started
to finish this thing up,
so for the average Democrat
that gets everything you've
said here, that they get it,
but they're just afraid,
afraid of being
called a Republican,
called a conservative,
afraid of being called
a Trump supporter,
you know, all the stuff
that it sounds like you
got over at some point,
I got over at some point,
but I get that those
are legit fears.
What's your best pitch
sort of as a candidate,
but also as kind of like a
thought leader in this thing
to be like, yeah, we're
not all bad over here?
- You know, my best
pitch is first of all,
the people who are
complaining about the country
voting for Republicans,
voting for Trump,
they actually do care
about the future,
they just want their kids
to live in a good country,
and that's what animates them.
But I think a lot of
people on the left
are never gonna really hear that
or appreciate that
or understand that.
But I think that the pitch
that I make to our own side
is that we have to be courageous
and we have to speak up, right?
Obviously there are exceptions,
there are people who
are gonna get fired
if they say the
wrong thing at work,
that's actually, unfortunately
a complaint that I hear
pretty frequently when I'm
out on the campaign trail,
but we just have to
actually speak up
about this stuff, right?
Like I was called
a white supremacist
in the pages of the
"Washington Post,"
I almost lost a couple
of business contacts,
it was a very bad
two days for me,
but then the dust cleared,
I didn't apologize,
I didn't back down,
and things were fine,
and I think so often
what we need to do
and what we need in this moment
is courage and friendship.
We need our friends to
be courageous as well,
you know, we need to know
they're supporting us,
but we just need to like
actually stand up to the mob
because I think every time
somebody stands up to the mob
and the mob backs down,
our side becomes a
little bit more powerful.
- That is a closing statement.
J.D. Vance, it was good
finally talking to you,
I'm sure our paths
will cross again.
- Dave, thanks for having me
and for folks who are interested
in helping the campaign,
JDVance.com, please
go to our website,
would love to have your support.
- Now I know you're
a real politician.
We'll link to it down below too.
All right, thanks, man.
- Thanks, man.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist,
and if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.